it's a shocking thing selling women's
shoes is shocking like
first of all all women lie about the
size of their foot
[Music]
you got this idea to be a
uh like a dj like a bar mitzvah dj
wedding dj sweet 16 dj right you play
records and what like well i yeah i had
it started first where there was this
bar in kansas city
called
studebakers yeah it was it was like a
50s bar right and uh i was trying to
find a job waiting tables but i had
really long hair right i was probably
about i don't know 18 and i didn't want
to cut my hair and uh and so i went in
and they said uh you know i was looking
for this like a job as a waiter a bar
back and uh they weren't hiring i said
what about djs because i saw they had a
dj booth they go well actually yeah and
then they would do these things called
show times where every hour he had to
stand on the bar and do like hand jive
like one of those cheese ball kinds of
things
but i wound up auditioning to dj
did you know anything about music i mean
did you know what to play
i knew like 50 some 50s music yeah i had
i mean i had a pretty good idea of the
music to play but because you got to get
people up and dancing isn't that your
job yeah but this was a bar that
thankfully i uh i didn't have to do try
and get people up and dancing so much at
this kind of place right but i wound up
having to wear like a 50s pompadour wig
because i wouldn't cut my hair and they
wanted me to look it was just so it must
have looked really cool but it's really
cool like an elvis wig like an elvis wig
but then when i moved from kansas
because i was in kansas when i moved to
go to acting school i needed a job on
the weekends and so i thought all right
you know what i have dj experience right
so then i got hired with a company that
would do like weddings and bar mitzvahs
and things like that so that you were
the guy you were the wedding and uh yeah
for about a year wow and uh i guess i
guess that teaches you something it's
better than i guess being a waiter and
having to earn a living while you go to
acting i did that i did that performing
but i mean yeah yeah but it was also it
was also a real uh
i mean what where was what was your
character's name donnie the dweeb or
something well i had to you know it was
a job that i didn't really i didn't love
it that much and i always felt a little
bit like
god i got a bit of a douche i'm like
trying to get these kids out on the
floor and yes that was where i got to
keep the party going yeah and then it
was and then i remember about
i had two bar mitzvahs in one day
and it was on the second bar mitzvah
hour 18 or whatever and i lost i just
lost it and i was dancing with these
kids and i started dancing just
like a you know like a freak uh and
mocking the entire thing but they
thought the kids i was funny
so they kind of cleared the dance floor
a little bit and my boss got on the mic
and said hey it's donnie dweeb oh and
that became you and i was like oh god
i can't bail on this so i have to do it
oh no and then the following week there
was like another bar mitzvah and these
kids said hey are you the guy that does
the dork dance that became your thing
your thing and then it became and
honestly this it became my thing that i
hated to do
but then i would get requests and if i
got a request to dj a party i'd get an
extra 100 bucks
so
you get to new york because i want to
make this point because people think
this [ __ ] happens overnight and it
doesn't oh it doesn't it's
hard yes yeah it's a lot of it and it's
not really luck it's a lot of hard work
sweat and tears so you come to new york
to be a dancer you're living on some
guy's couch
yeah but that only lasted for like like
five days max so how do you get money
well i got a scholar i went to start
going to auditions and i got into some
dance companies
got a partial scholarship to the
elvenali school
and then i started just making little
bits of money you know and then i was
taking [ __ ] jobs i was i did everything
i worked at dunkin donuts i was the hat
chick did you get fired from dunkin
donuts in one day no i i think i stayed
there for maybe a week were you fired
because you scored a jelly over everyone
um i was playing with the jelly squirter
machine yeah and they just got pissed
off at you
yeah had you played your card right you
could have been a manager at dunkin
donuts i could be running i could be the
ceo
of dunkin donuts so some guy comes up to
you and says hey you're fired because
you're not taking the job seriously
that's right right
well you know what i got fired for at
the russian tea room i was a very good
hat check girl i must say i got bird for
wearing fishnets
is that right yeah and i couldn't i'm
like but you can't even see my legs i'm
behind a door
because they told you not to wear
fishnets but you said but it's your
nature to say
[ __ ] you i'm going to wear fishnets well
it's just my nature to do the opposite
of what people tell me to do even if
it's going to cost you a job and you
have i didn't know they were going to
fire me right it was just like code like
a dress code did you explain to them you
were madonna
i wasn't madonna then oh i mean it was
but not they didn't they didn't
recognize it they didn't see the future
when you decided to do american idol you
were working you had uh been on cruise
ships for disney was it the hercules
show i did hercules the musical where i
played california the head music and i
sang the circle of life soloists so it
was two shows like was it back
two days like tuesday and wednesday so
your career was one where things were
happening you were starting to make some
money because i mean disney was paying
yeah yes they were and that was legit
yeah that was legit disney is real
disney is real honey is that your first
real paycheck in the business actually
no my first real paycheck interview so
before then i worked at burger king
right
that was my job and i used to sing in
the drive-through right did you really
sing in the driver's seat yeah i used to
sing it because it was a mic honey yeah
so that was my stage so let's say i pull
up i go uh i'd like to have uh two fries
i don't know what i would be singing but
you would hear my mouth just
singing away and they'll pull up and
they're
like is that
you knew what car was coming because it
would be beep beep and my sister she was
like the queen of burger king and she
used to fuss at me do your job you know
you don't know what you're doing but i
just want to sing a song so i was
singing there
and
somehow like the
head manager of burger king was a club
promoter too oh so he started to hire me
to sing at his clubs
and i started making more money
singing one night at the club then i did
for two weeks at burger king burning my
face on the boiler and all of that stuff
and i was like how long were you at
burger king
peg that's a good question
was it months or years the first job the
first time i worked there i was 16.
right but then i quit right because it
was just not for me and then i
eventually went back and i think i was
there maybe
a year or two
it's hard work isn't it it is it is and
did you make fries did you did you do
everything i
yeah the second time around the first
time i couldn't do nothing right right
but the second time yes i used to do all
the burgers and
the fries um but mainly work in the
drive-through and singing but isn't it
great that here you were a burger king
of course gave you an opportunity to
make a couple of bucks but isn't it
great that sort of you got discovered
and started working in clubs because the
guy at burger king recorded what a lucky
break
and isn't this a lesson in a sense that
wherever you are sing if you want to be
a singer and who knows and do your best
job even if you're a burger king and
maybe somebody will discover you yeah
that's what i was thinking back then you
know because you don't even know who
might be driving through right you don't
know and even like i have people singing
to me today you know i'll be like oh
lord they thinking like i was thinking
back then
every time you went to the corner
oh my god i was just like that did they
do that to you do people come up and
sort of audition and say they'll just be
like wondering around whether close
enough so you hear them
you were
a young guy one of the jobs you had i
don't think we ever talked about this
you were a santa claus in a store right
really yes now where now where did you
do that
i just moved to san diego
uh san diego what you know i always
think you just think perverts take those
jobs so they can get kids on their left
we were talking about that yesterday is
there a school or
yeah i mean that whole santa business is
is something else i mean i mean some
guys just that's all they live for is
christmas these older guys are they
throw the beards out it seems like it'd
be a good job though do you get paid a
decent amount not a good job why is it
bad well for me it was i was 23 at the
time 24 right thin you know i didn't
even i look like a kid i should have
been sitting on santa's lap
yeah you were barely a man and i was in
san diego i just moved out from
connecticut brought into stand up and i
was and i want to check out san diego
first and so my buddy and i worked for
manpower temporary help agency so we had
a lot of like part-time jobs you know
and um and
they were everything from like cleaning
out warehouses right you know pulling
weeds out of a parking lot whatever work
you could grab for the day whatever you
could do and you didn't need a lot you
just need enough to pay you know the
hotel or whatever and so um um we got a
job uh working in santa clauses they
asked for you know for two months
and um i worked in the sears department
store in north uh park in san diego but
you probably say to yourself hey this
beats clearing out a warehouse all i can
do is sit here and just talk to these
kids oh yeah and you're a star here
comes the santa claus right you know you
got the beard you got the do you have
the fact that yeah
uh we had a little stuffing in there
about as much as 400 francs you're like
a skinny santa it really was yeah and it
was just like a cotton beard it was so
cheap and they were really cutting so
many corners
and and basically it's to get it's to
make money and taking pictures right
right that's where they make the money
in the photo department and a lot of the
kids from tijuana would come over really
and a lot of them were scared and they
would pee on your lap are you [ __ ]
me
in your lap
jesus but the i think the santa agency
knew of this that would happen so they
scotch guarded all their clothes so the
pee would just bubble up and roll off
the way is that true yeah you're not
making this up no no no no no telling me
they treated the santa claus outfits
with special scotch gardening so that
the pee because they knew beat it up and
rolled off howard i'm telling you that
they sprayed these suits with the
scotchgard oh my god this is huge uh
this is news
this is you just you've just broken news
that no one ever realized
so when you get out of college because
you say [ __ ] college you were doing it
on a football scholarship there's no
point to play football and and and get
and go to school if you don't want to go
to school like you know you only go to
school if you want to and you get out
and you're doing you know you're framing
houses like the old man you know you're
doing some construction right 7.75 an
hour and all this and did things look
bleak to you at that point because what
are you about 19 years old uh you know i
i kind of yeah i was definitely like
freaking out like what am i gonna do uh
with my life because i'm not playing
football anymore and that was kind of
the only goal and you're not going to
school yeah definitely not going to go
to school so i guess in my mind i was
like okay i'm just going to get a job
and work my way up somewhere and and
figure it out you know i didn't have any
grand plans or anything and then the
grand plan becomes i'm going to sell
samples at dillard's like what are
samples like perfume
i mean it sounds like a real good plan
you had going there yeah
infinite knowledge yeah
would you walk up to women in the
department stores i was the guy chasing
you like with like the little piece of
paper or whatever that you spray and
then you give it to him
what a horrible [ __ ] terrible it was
horrible and basically i was just hung
over the whole time in there anyway and
you guys can't understand what the
lights of dillard's do and like what the
music that they play inside of that
thing when like you're just you just
you're just so hungover and you want to
go were you hired because i mean look
you're doing this you're trying to
figure out your life and then you see an
ad
and the ad says hey make 19 bucks an
hour as an exotic dancer right is that
something like yeah they were just they
didn't tell how much money which if i'd
have no no probably wouldn't win but
because it's not that much it's not that
much money i mean guys don't make what
females trip no not even well it's one
of the only jobs that it doesn't happen
like that and i picked that so he picked
the one career
yeah
genius stripping yes but like that's a
very
that's a big deal to decide i'm gonna go
be a male stripper right i mean like
guys would go hey that's great but
meanwhile going up on a stage
and taking off your [ __ ] cl do you
have to show your [ __ ] no but you
basically see it i mean
you see everything there's no real
there's very little to the imagination
what is it like when you're a kid i
guess you were about what 20 years old
19 years old when i was 19. 19. what is
it like when you see this ad and you go
in for your audition who's auditioning
you probably think you're probably going
to be killed or sold off i mean i was 19
had a sister went in she my sister was
not happy about it she even showed up
the first night to try to shame me out
of going on yeah i mean she was super
unhappy
like a guy who danced a lot and
everything yeah that's kind of the whole
reason why i went in i i wasn't big i
wasn't like really big i was kind of
like more just skinny and i don't know
could dance
were there actual dancers that wouldn't
change their routine like took it that
seriously um
yeah i mean
they wouldn't they wouldn't
change them because they were theirs
they just i don't know they they
basically would change them because they
they knew they worked right you know i
like they convinced me to go out and do
a clown routine one night
and i think i just got picked on when i
was like because i was like the kid and
yeah
i was like guys this is gonna [ __ ]
terrify them you gotta understand like
this is not gonna work and and i'm come
out with balloons and [ __ ] big old
red feet and everything how is that good
how are you guys excuse me i can carry
out to 99 red balloons look at this song
or something and you could just even
though the song was playing you could
tell that everyone wanted to run
yeah and then i think i just took the
[ __ ] off and then like no one clapped
and then i was like okay wow that's it
for now on i'm doing my own routines for
now on
for 10 years you're doing the shittiest
jobs
in la what was the list of jobs that you
did in la that that just to make a
living well i do want to clarify one
because people always ask me if i worked
at a hot dog cart
yes i've heard that it's very different
i worked at a hot dog restaurant
oh well
very different well no it was actually
this little one whenever i describe it
it sounds crazy i've never heard it it
was like a little it was
what was it was in beverly hills and it
was a like a gourmet
hot dog place and actually one of the
first
celebrities that i ever met was john
lovitz and he came in there
i made him a hot dog is that why in the
new movie you make hot dog soup i like
the salt i like the hat dad maybe that's
a subconscious that's what you did you
wrote it yeah when lovitz walks in
and uh he's a fan of your hot dogs does
he hit on you because you know john was
probably saying he didn't
no but i remember he's not even gonna
know this story he he came in and i
remember he he came in and he had just
bought like a new camera or something
and he was just kind of like figuring it
out and we were like talked about it and
then
but i was freaking out because i when i
first got to la like i you know i
remember the very first celebrity i saw
was joey butterfucko and a cvs
wow
that was my first sighting
it was my first sighting
and john lovitz was was soon after and i
was so
excited
where'd you grow up
iowa iowa i mean you had some [ __ ] jobs
right i had some bad jobs you mowed
lawns everybody's done that i was a
dishwasher in a kitchen i worked in a
supermarket deli you were always
industrious i was a roofer for a while
how the hell did you get all these jobs
i mean how do you go from roofing my dad
had a construction company my stepdad
had a construction company and so when i
was like
nine years old i was on a construction
site like cleaning up and
i just always got told that you got to
work your way through life and if you
don't work you know what are you gonna
get and and we didn't have a lot of
money so if i actually wanted to buy
things for me i had to go make money so
i always had a job since i was 12. but
when you were in high school you were a
football player right yeah i played
football and uh you never missed a game
one game you missed
one play guy yeah you missed one play
threw up on the field i mean they made
me get off because the guy kicked you in
the stomach right yeah well i tackled a
guy and got a foot in the gut but you
were that guy like you did choir you did
acting you were in the acting society
did wrestling you did track yeah
and then i went to work and then what
age did they say all of a sudden you're
in high school someone says hey you
ought to go be a model not in high i
went to college oh and then i was i was
going to the university of iowa and
uh i was in a bar and this woman married
clark
uh who was a model scout in iowa of all
places came into music have you ever
thought of even being a model i was like
no i thought about being an actor and
she's like well it's a good way to be an
actor and i was like okay wow and so i
won a contest and i moved to new york
and i had 100 bucks in my pocket what
kind of contest a modeling contest you
mean like they they submit they set up a
thing in a shopping mall and i walk from
like here to the other side of the room
oh my god and i want it against other
good looking dudes against other good
looking and you win and i won you know i
was in that contest and they threw
stones at me did you know that yeah yeah
i still i still twitch from it
so what is it you won that contest how
many dudes were in that contest i have
no idea and what do you wear like just
like i like blue jeans and a t-shirt but
you have to wear a bathing suit no i
just i holy so [ __ ] so then i i came to
new york and for this for another
contest which i got like second place
josh dumel won the contest that's a good
looking dude handsome son of josh
do you hate him i was so [ __ ] upset
at this guy for so long and then finally
i ran into him i was like all right
you're good-looking right i had to give
it up like right like so anyways right
so you come in second which isn't bad in
new york i mean uh yeah listen i was
like you know and like and
so i like that you lost the job yeah
good little adversity is good that's
good you know i'm coming in second the
story of the life
when you're growing up in new jersey was
your dream always to be a stand-up
comedian no that was like my worst
nightmare what did you want to be i
think i just wanted like people to hear
what i had to say like i thought my
opinion was very valuable at a very
young age and because i'm the youngest
of six you just have to scream and yell
to get hurt so that was definitely you
know a part of the were you a loudmouth
yeah and you would mouth off about
everything did you ever go up on a stage
and do stand up for a career
yeah was that your start yeah that's how
i started yeah and you'd go up and you
do your thing and you talk were you good
at it um i got good at it i mean yeah
you know in the beginning i had an
easier time i think if it had been more
difficult in the beginning i would have
probably given up more easily but i
had an easy time and then i went through
the rough patch like you know a year
into it where i would bomb all the time
you mean the first time you got up you
were good at it well i i mean you know i
had like 15 friends in the audience too
so where did you do that where did you
go the first time on melrose and then
the laugh factory
was it like oh my god i got to go do
this i better go take 50 drinks and get
up on that stage how old were you i had
to have like eight more ingredients 20.
you were 20 years old and you walked up
on a stage for the first time did you
have stuff written down that you were
going to talk about yeah and you were
really well thought out about this and
who inspired all of this in you was
there some some person or some comedian
that you looked up to no i no i didn't
want to do stand-up it was just kind of
like the my
what else to do yeah i was auditioning
and i was reading these people's lines
you know you go on auditions and
everyone's skinnier and prettier and i'm
like i'm jewish and i like i'm never
gonna be like like a supermodel type
girl and i just didn't even have any
interest in that i just thought i wanted
something where i could express my my
opinions and my point of view
without anyone kind of editing me and
and what do you mean you were
auditioning you were going out and
trying to what get on tv shows yeah like
no no like to to be an actress yeah and
i was a terrible auditioner i mean i
couldn't even i mean that that situation
was way more comfortable than going on
stage right you could just do what you
wanted and then if you don't get laughs
you act like that was on purpose did you
begin to lose faith in yourself because
you'd go out and audition for tv shows
or commercials or whatever the hell and
did you begin to say you know maybe i'm
not a performer yeah all the time i was
like oh my god what if because i was
waiting tables for six or seven years
and where at oh my god everywhere
there's a place called roasty shy of
venice everywhere in la and i got fired
from every job i ever had why because
you didn't listen to authority because i
would go off on people like if i didn't
like like if some customers my customers
and my managers right like the manager
my manager was this coke head you know
and he and he was just running and it
was like this lunch in place it wasn't
even appropriate to be doing cocaine at
that time
and he was just in front of the help
they'd be running around you know he's
like this italian guy was like you know
he's clearly jacked
yeah and i just went off on him i was
like can you just wait and do coke to
when it gets dark out like i can't tell
your boss went to do coke a regular
person right or i would go off on people
if they left me crappy tips i'd be like
you're an [ __ ] and you know like you
know you'd have big parties and people
don't understand this in in anywhere in
tipping and this is why i'm very
sensitive to it because i tip like 500
when i go out because i know what it's
like right and you'd go you know i had a
table of these guys and you always know
it's bad when they start out like we're
going to take care of you we got you
tonight don't worry about us i'm like oh
[ __ ] you're getting you're getting maybe
20 if you're lucky there's not going to
be anything over right so and so we had
these guys and and and i was at this
restaurant venice in in venice
california and he said and this guy said
that and you know it's like an 800 bill
it ended up being like a bar tab i
worked in the bar and it was a bar it
was really nice restaurant bar and so i
and you know you have to pay taxes on
that especially when they pay with a
credit card you have to pay people don't
know that the waitress has to pay like
eight percent of that so if you're not
even tipping me eight percent i'm
basically paying for you to go out to
dinner wow i didn't know that yes so you
have to pay a portion of your sales that
are not in cash right so the guys you
know they they he got money i saw him
collecting money from his whole group
and then you know on 800 he took me like
ten dollars wow and i went right up to
him in front of everyone and i was like
and his last name was some jewish thing
and i was like listen it's jews like you
that could choose like me a bad name and
i said just so you all know he took me
ten dollars took your money took me took
me ten dollars on 800 and probably
pocketed the rest so have a great night
and congratulations on your friend and
you got fired for that well yeah i guess
so but but yet you have you have a good
point in fact i've gone to dinner with
friends
who i look over and i see what they're
tipping and i go i would rather just pay
the bill so i can give the waiter a
decent tip absolutely i don't trust the
some of the people that i dine with to
do the right thing by tipping so people
are always like chelsea you have to stop
paying and i'm like i'd rather settle
this and i don't like people talking
about spending money like paying like oh
i'll get this you get that it's like
just somewhere okay it's just somebody
i'm not splitting it i'm not eight okay
we don't need to split this
i've done some really terrible tv shows
you know
i did one show where i played an
undercover cop on a harley during the
day and a rock star at night it's called
sunset beat
i've gotten the job but i didn't know
how to play the guitar and there'd be
like a full like concert of like you
know 8 000 people out there and be up
there pretending to play guitar i don't
even know how to move my hands you know
during that those 14 years or something
did you ever say geez i got to give this
up i got to find something else the
truth of the matter is the first two
years you know i was broke i was
sleeping on the floor or closet and i
had a didn't have a car i rode a bicycle
all around hollywood for auditions and
you know and i did construction work and
a lot of
you know other jobs to get by
but once i started working
i was making
you know enough money that i didn't have
to take another job so i always felt
like you know i'm a journeyman actor i'm
just going to keep plugging away and you
know hopefully i'll get some good roles
as i go i didn't think i was going to
get
as late you know it was a 35 when it hit
so just amazing i mean because you were
doing like facts of life uh golden girls
you were on roseanne i remember when you
uh said you yeah you know you were you
were doing that gig you don't feel
like you know what i should give it up
because obviously what was i going to
give up i'd go back and sell ladies
shoes that's by the way let me just say
that it's a shocking thing
being in the selling women's shoes is
shocking like
first of all all women lie about the
size of their foot i don't know why that
is so true they don't want you to be
seen
this is a seven and you go this is a 10.
you know you're trying to jam this 10
into a seven
right and there was a whole generation
of these women this is like 1979
1980
and i was working this department store
and there's a whole generation of women
who so probably were born like in 1910
or something they got their
you know their fourth toe cut off
right so they could fit into the pumps
really their toes fit and what are your
other jobs was they had this this wooden
shoe horn
and it had it was like a mr potato head
had all these holes in it with a plastic
corn
now remember those and they would come
in and i'd have to i'd have to spread
blue powder on their corn
what a horrible job put the shoe on and
then go and look and then put the corn
and stretch a cornhole
what you're saying george is that when
you're on the set of the attack of the
killer tomatoes you're going this is
fantastic
i am not putting powder on corns
when i'm when i'm sandpapering my bat
nipples off i'm still going i'm good man